one minute
now we got a couple got one missing okay
pretty good
attemp thank you it being 10:00 I will
call the finance committee to
order um and I'll begin with we'll
introduce ourselves some of us are new
to the committee so just so we get to
know each other a little better uh my
name name is pronounced wer Ken Wier uh
I'm the chairman of this committee for
another term I've been on the uh finance
committee since 94 been in the house
since 90 uh I'm an MIT grad I went to
the Air Force pilot training right out
of college had a 38-year career in uh
flying both uh Air Force and American
Airlines many of those years overlapped
and uh first elected in a special
election in 1990 and had one year I
missed out in a in lost an election got
in a special election a year later so 3
34 years total in in the house and uh
Vice chair Dan
Maguire thank you Mr chairman so uh my
name is Dan Maguire I'm from Epsom I'm a
retired computer engineer this will be
my fifth term in the house all in
Finance I was on division 2 once
division three twice and this will be my
SEC second term on division one which
I'm also chairing um and also an MIT grd
also an MIT grd yeah I only went to MIT
for 11 years
so so um and and our our ranking member
and and DEA the
house thank you Dan I'm Mary Jane walner
and as Dan just told you I'm the dean of
the house because I'm going into my 23rd
term so and of that
probably 22 or three terms I mean no 22
or three years have been on finance so
um I've been here for quite a while
always on division three and last year I
had the opportunity to spend some time
on division one and uh that was that was
really eye opening for me because so
many different agencies um I went to UNH
not not MIT great school UNH and um glad
to be here and glad to meet all of you
and see all
you um my name is Karen eil I'm the
deputy ranking member um I did not go to
MIT and I've never flown a plane but my
husband uh did have a private airplane
once anyway um I have been in the house
I'm headed into my seventh term I spent
five terms on public works and highways
working on the capital budget and that
sort of thing um I'm a New Hampshire
native I grew up in oap New Hampshire um
I ended up going to Georgetown and I
have a legal background although I
haven't practiced law for quite some
time and that's probably all you need to
know about
me hi oh boy I'm Daniel popovic Mueller
second term member both on finance 2 and
um born and raised in a communist
country got my degree there in
engineering then I got an MBA from
Boston University in the US I've worked
on the business side for an IT startup
did a bunch of stuff including Technical
Training I taught for a living for 10
years I worked in corporate finance I
worked in government finance and uh you
know here we are working on state
finances so uh
if you need to know more about me I'm
known to talk way too much so be careful
about asking questions in a private
setting thank
you I'm Harry Bean I'm from bellnap
County this is my fourth term third term
in
finance um I live on a piece of property
in Guilford that my family has owned and
lived on since
1842 I guess that's I
am Gary Daniels I live in mil Milford
this is my 10 10th term in the house uh
my first nine terms I was on the labor
committee then I went to the senate for
three terms where I chaired the Senate
finance committee for two of those my
last two terms there and now I'm back in
the house glad to be here thank
you good morning my name is Mary hackin
Phillips and my last name is pronounced
like hack like computer
hack uh I represent hover in Lime I'm in
my third term my first term I served on
Ways and Means and the second term I was
here with you in finance and I'm glad to
be back I'm a lawyer by trade um but I
have a background before that in the
financial and banking SE
sector so I'm just so pleased to be back
again thank
you my name is uh Chris muns um I grew
up in the uh in the Detroit area so um
you could you'll understand why I'm
pretty excited uh about the the football
season this year um it's been a long
time coming um I um first came to New
Hampshire when I um arrived in Hanover
to um uh get my uh Masters in Business
Administration degree from Dartmouth and
have been here pretty much ever since um
I um spent most of my um professional
career in the private sector working in
a variety of uh financial management and
um HR management
positions um and when I left the private
sector um I spent five years as the CEO
of uh one of our state's 10 um area
agencies that provide supports to uh
individuals with developmental
disabilities this is my third term in
the house uh I don't know what it says
about me but um I get moved to a
different committee every term I started
in Commerce I spent the last term in
science technology and energy and now
I'm very happy to be here in
finance hi I'm Brian seaworth um with my
degree in engineering came from
RPI um this is my seventh term in the
house uh my first term back in 2011 I
was on chairman Daniels committee labor
and that's where I've been uh for 12
years now I was four years the clerk of
that committee four years the vice chair
of that committee and two years in the
minority um so I'm looking forward to uh
learning some new things serving here on
finance the budget is one of the most
important duties of the house and I hope
to contribute to making that a success
thank you
good morning I'm Kate Murray I'm from
Newcastle and represent Newcastle and U
Portsmouth um this is my fifth term
fourth on finance my first term was on
criminal justice and Public Safety um I
come out of Academia although it's been
a really really really long time since I
was in Academia I have advanced degrees
in the psychology of music from the
University of Illinois and advanced
degrees in theology from UC Berkeley and
graduate theological Union
um I have enjoyed being on finance and L
uh this has been a really good committee
and a very um commit where you I've
learned uh so much and I've really
enjoyed learning all that and expect to
continue to do that so thank
you hi everyone Joe Sweeney from Salem I
uh work in marketing I also attended the
University of New Hampshire uh for
undergraduate Masters and uh is my
second term on finance fifth term
overall and I'm excited to be back with
all of you looking forward to it thank
you
hi representa we
start I'm Jerry Griffin I'm your
clerk um I'll have more to say about
that in a minute I have a um after
college I went into the air force they
made me in into an aircraft engineer and
I served as an aircraft mainten
maintenance officer I have service in
Vietnam when I came back from that I got
a master's degree and at the same time
sat for the CPA exam and passed it so I
practiced in in Industry as a CPA most
of my time was in Industry this is my uh
fourth term in the house all of which
have been spent on finance given my
background I want to warn you all about
one thing I don't care what your name is
Smith or Jones I have the abillity you
mispronounce it and I ask you all for
forgiveness right up front thank
you yeah hello I'm U representative Jess
Edwards representing uh Auburn Chester
Candia and Deerfield it's so this is my
fifth term uh very happy to be back um
background um I was married 41 years
I've got uh two daughters adult
daughters and a granddaughter very proud
of them um fun fact uh I'm the only
hospital administrator in US military
history to have established a com combat
arms training facility uh capable of
training three battalions simultaneously
in a hostile fire zone so um so if you
need any armed combatants uh come talk
to me I hope hopefully the budget won't
be that
contentious um I um I think my
specialties are in health care finance
and it um and uh I'm very happy to have
a nice set of additional duties uh in
the legislature to do that like HHS
oversight The Joint fiscal committee um
the it Council uh that sort of thing so
uh happy to be here and I didn't get to
hear everyone's introduction so if you
could just repeat it quickly I'd U and
I'm sorry I'm late
hi excuse me I'm Representative Keith th
from we I grew up in Connecticut and uh
went to school in Boston and then moved
up to New Hampshire work for a startup
company when that didn't go well I
started my own company and my own
software Services Company software
application and development company and
been there for sever since um I it's my
fourth term in the house uh fourth term
on finance first three were on uh
division three with uh representative
Edwards chairman Edwards and uh this
year I'm switching it up and I'm on
division two um as the
chairman good morning everyone my name
is Moren money I'm in my sixth term
representing the town of marac in
Hillsboro County currently I'm the vice
chair of division 3 previous to finance
of which I've been on for a term and a
half I've served on the election law
committee the judicial committee and the
rules committee and have held various
positions within the caucus I look
forward to this term thank you all very
much good morning my name is Peter
leechman this is my 13th term in the
house nine of which I've spent here on
the finance committee uh on division one
during those nine terms I'm uh outside
of the legislature I'm in the railroad
business and um I'm happy to be here as
well thank you Mr chairman
good morning my name is Jose cells uh
I'm from Lowden and I represent
Canterbury and Lowden I'm a Northeastern
graduate and uh a retired engineering
executive in the military electronics
Industry this is my third term my first
term I served on Science Tech and energy
and um these last two terms I'll be on
finance division one and I am now the
vice chair of division one and I greatly
appreciate that honor thank you
good morning I'm Laura tersi um I grew
up in the NASA neighborhood that I now
represent this is my fourth term in the
house uh my first two terms I served on
the house Transportation committee and
last term joined uh my friends on
division 3 I have a degree in history
from Georgetown University and a
master's degree in Middle Eastern
studies from the University of Chicago
and I'm happy to be here
good morning everyone I'm David priest I
represent Hillsboro District 17 in
Manchester um I um received my graduate
and doctoral studies degree from the
University of Wisconsin
Madison and I practice as an urban and
Regional planner um for 44 years both in
the public and private sector
uh I've been in New Hampshire now for 20
years uh I came here to serve as the
executive director and CEO for the
Southern New Hampshire Planning
Commission in U in the Manchester area
and I've this is my second term in the
house I served both on the municipal and
a half a year on division 3 in finance
and it gives me great pleasure to be
back with all of you thank
you wow I'm the new be I guess I'm the
only one I'm or originally from KY Maine
went to um Trae Academy University of
Southern Maine my Tour of Duty um these
last years have been in finance I was a
banker commercial mortgage lender also
um I ran VP of operations then I moved
on to manufacturing where I worked as in
a startup position of a multimedia firm
that was International I took it I
didn't take it public we took it public
and then after that I moved on to a
short term of retirement then I went in
um to education for a little while
served 10 years on the mon School of New
England I was the project manager and
fundraiser to build that school I now
retired or I thought I was but I'm back
in
business good morning my name is Eileen
Kelly and I represent uh marac District
8 which is Bradford the town I live in
and hener M Warner and I am a former uh
staff person here at the state house for
a total of 22 years senior policy uh
assistant in the Democratic office uh
and then my last two years I served as
chief of staff for um speaker shirtliff
so um I'm very familiar with a lot of
you having been here so long um and I
have a ba in English thank
you and last but not least and Susan
you're not alone I'm a newbie as well
rich noveno I represent uh chesher
District 9 which is elstead Gilson Marlo
Stoddard uh I my background in education
is we've been in New Hampshire for 24
years retire ired here after a extensive
career in the international oil and
energy business which uh had us living
in Tokyo Japan for four years Hong Kong
for two London England for seven and
have had the opportunity to travel to 63
different countries none of them in
South America one in Africa so unless
you're really good at geography you
might have a hard time after you get out
of the uh European theater and been to a
lot of places that aren't going to have
tourist business in our lifetimes my
background I have an engineering degree
from Cornell
University uh and then an MBA from the
University of Pittsburgh um I'm
originally from the western Pennsylvania
area at with a major in finance um most
of my experience has been in and out of
the uh Finance area in various different
uh corporate level um in charge of
Finance for uh an international division
of a major Fortune 500 company uh I
currently uh have five grown kids all of
them college educated and 15 grandkids
so have a vested interest in making sure
that uh and half of those are in New
Hampshire so I have a vested interest in
making sure that we're all doing the
best for the future uh citizens of uh of
New
Hampshire thank
you what an impressive group of talent
we should have no problem with this
budget so we like to start on time if
you're not going to make it please make
sure someone knows about it and if it's
24 hours in advance we can get a
replacement for you but if we don't know
in advance then we can't um hopefully
you have an uh an email account you'll
give to Janet you'll meet her shortly
she's our denm mother and uh she has a
full-time job one of the few committee
assistants that's here year round
because there's so much to do and she
has to catch up on all the minutes on
all the the Committees that we've met
after after we finished our session um
we're all properly dressed I expect we
will be for the rest of the time
remember that we're on TV for a lot of
this and I will always address you
because of the fact we're on TV you know
I'd like to say Dan and and Jerry but
know it's representative Maguire
representative Griffin because it's all
going out over TV and being recorded um
we have a coffee Fund in this in this
committee and we also have a lunchroom
at the back corner there uh there's a
little refrigerator some of you might
keep a lunch in there I don't know if
it's going to hold all of them but uh if
you wanted to do it there's usually
space there um sometimes when we just
have a short time for lunch it's it's
handy that we can all come back there
and there's room for about half of us to
eat lunch back there uh if you if you
brought your lunch um as I said because
of and Janet quite often has goodies
there if if everybody pays their $20 a
year for the coffee fund and you'll have
uh free coffee and so on for just just
for the members of the committee don't
invite others in to to use up our coffee
um we won't won't have food or or coffee
on the table table during our hearings
if you're really thirsty water's okay
but don't have stuff on the table we
always going to have a lot of paperwork
we don't want to spill anything on it
that makes a stain on you the floor or
the paperwork
um anybody has a medical issue make sure
we know we know about it or I know about
it or you you're Cherry your division
electronic devices U please have your
phones turned off don't think I did that
to mine yet um
so uh we don't we don't get Disturbed uh
a few of us will have a chairs and vice
chairs will have an office the others
you will have assigned in that room
there a drawer where you where the Janet
will put you paperwork that you'll need
to have for the Committees
um the two members at the end of the
table representative Sweeney and
representative Nena um if we have a
problem with somebody testifying I may
give you a signal to go out and get
somebody from security to come in and
deal with it
um fire alarm and we exit out here and
we'll probably be assembling across the
street
um so as you
know rule
31 all spending bills originate in the
house and in this committee were
assigned by the the others um it's a he
it's a heavy lift especially with the
budget every other year and unlike other
committees we have the best assistance
have the legislative budget assistance
Mr Kaine will introduce himself shortly
and the three people sitting over there
are also some of the Geniuses that keep
us on score on Dan there four where's
the fourth oh there he is he's sitting
sitting at the proper place sorry sorry
about that um you'll get to all these
people introduced there's uh some in
each division and and Mike is in charge
of all of them he the dean because quite
often a lot of these people that he he
brings on board most of them are CPA uh
somebody steals them somewhere else in
state government so he's constantly
educating people he's the dean of the
College of of Finance people so uh
you'll get to introd get to introduce
him himself shortly
um we have um 14 Republicans and 10
Democrats in the committee um all the
all the bills that will have a fiscal
note on them will likely come to us
unless it's a fee or a tax and then 11
what do I say
11 14 14 and 11 okay sorry and
uh that's what you're here for keep me
straight um
so we'll we'll see we'll see bills from
virtually every committee if they have a
committee that and a policy committee
and a deals with it it has a cost to it
they'll send it to us normally in the
first year of the budget we just
includeed in the budget if we look at if
it's passed through the house comes to
us we'll send it to a division of of
appropriate
um appropriate subject matter and then
we'll we'll try to include it in the
budget um it's going to be more
difficult this year so I've tried to get
each policy committee to deal with the
spending within their expertise in other
words if you're fishing game and
somebody says oh we need three new such
and such and you say well find another
place where you can take three from and
replace them with these three rather
than come to us and expect us to add
more employees so that's one of the
things I've asked them to do but we'll
see how that works out um but normally
in the first year we were able to put a
lot of the things in the second year
it's a little more difficult unless
there's a big Surplus
um we already have three of our people
assigned to the new committee on
education
spending representative McGuire
representative
F who pich Mller representative papichi
Mller and they'll so they'll
be juggling both of those committee
Works um it'll affect one we schedule
ours um the subcommittees we have three
divisions you'll you'll know hear about
those in the
afternoon uh keep checking the calendar
including your personal calendars if you
put any bills in that's sometimes the
only way you find about oh tomorrow I
got a bill I've got to introduce in such
and such a place
um if you're looking at a bill file to
to write the um report on it that goes
to the house do not not remove it from
this building uh sit down and work on it
also when we have a uh when you make the
the motion you'll have to make the
report and be ready to go to the floor
and have that ready before you leave the
building um committee replacement I
discussed let people know uh if it's if
you call your partisan office then
they'll do their best to have someone
fill in for you the next day and give
them an idea what what the bills are
that will be um
exact we'll have a lot of people come
before us um you'll find conflicting
testimony from two different
Witnesses it's not our role to say wait
a minute the last person said that you
shouldn't be right no we don't debate
them we listen
patiently and when we come to the exact
session then we'll discuss what we
believe the version of the truth was we
won't challenge people that come to us
because our job is to listen and not
have a lot of searching questions you
can have a question if you think they
stated something wrong and give them a
chance to restate it but if don't argue
with them if they
don't
um don't make a speech when you want to
make a question just ask the question
and get wait till I recognize you to to
ask the chair to ask the question
uh and when you when a bill that you
have sponsored comes before us you will
sit out in the audience rather than at
your regular seat and you won't be able
to ask the other people that come after
you to discuss your bill you won't be
able to ask them questions uh that's
just the way it is because it's got to
be a fair thing they've got to have a
fair hearing rather than a debate with
you we will debate it in the executive
committee and you can have notes and
tell us all the people that said the
wrong things and we will listen to you
um conflict of interest and recusal
might might come about
um and make sure that it's known if it's
known we should all know it
also
um what's the other thing we may have a
chance if we have several bills to work
on I might put in the calendar uh
executive sessions may follow if if
there's time available in other words we
thought we were going to have a have 45
minutes on a bill we had 10 left us 35
minutes so okay we just heard two other
bills before that um without objection
from the minor with the ranking member
we we'll ask to have an exact session uh
on some bills that seemed fairly
apparent how how people felt about them
and we'll try to fit in those exact
sessions just to kind of save us money
save us time um
when we have an executive session it's
just us and normally we're hearing from
division one then division two division
three because we'll hear we'll have most
bills will have a full hearing
here the subject matter will go to the
appropriate division they'll have
another hearing and they'll make a
decision and a recommendation to the
full committee then when we come back
for an exec session for all the bills
that have been before the committee
we'll start with division one we'll go
through them
and then we'll go through division two
division three and so on and you will
tell us we will know when we sit down
what the recommendation was from the
division which will help help us guide
us to how we'll decide um the people
that make the Motions will likely uh
write the report and defend it on the
floor uh committee report Minority
Report uh make sure we know if you're if
you're on the other side and you and you
want to make sure there's a Minority
Report make sure that that The Minority
Report is known and we'll have that in
the in the uh calendar as well so I want
to say more about the legislative budget
assistant we we have the most work of
any committee but we have the most help
and some of you are used to running back
and forth across the street in other
committees to try to get an amendment
these people know how to do it a lot
quicker so I will turn it over to to uh
the legislative budget assistant Mike
Kaine and he will explain what what you
have before you and you have a nice
briefing that he's going to go over and
also uh another thing that I put on each
of your
places this is a list of
paychecks that the treasurer has given
me so when you have a group come before
you and you look at the page and the the
the uh the numbers in the column will
tell you where to look like 02700 for
Employment Security Department and how
many employees they have
because what I've discovered in 16
budgets that I've now the 16th budget is
that they quite often pad the number of
employees and then when you try to ask
the question well how many are really
working well you know we had a bunch of
people that are going to already retire
and we got some more people in the
pipeline and we're interviewing more
you know this is the number we hope we'd
get and you never hear the true number
and sometimes you'd say I used to the
last budget I had one month of what the
real paycheck yeah but we were we were
had more people coming so this way we
can look back and see how many people
you had over the whole year so don't
come in and add 10 or 15 more employees
to it this is going to be a tight budget
and a lot of the money will come from
not funding empty position
and we've been doing that for years we
do our best to avoid it this is the
mechanism I've chosen the uh Treasurer
can give me an accurate account of how
many paychecks get issued to that
Division and if you didn't have 150
paychecks issued over the last year why
are you asking for 150 people when the
most you've had is
135 so these are these are some of the
things that I hope will save us money as
we go through this budget those are the
things that I want each you to have a
copy of that division two and three are
on the back because they don't have
nearly as
many departments to deal with as
division one does so those are a good
guide as you look at their
proposal this is how many people we want
this is how many people you had for a
whole year so very handy stuff we can
save a lot lot of money by not funding
vacant positions
so thank
you Mr
Kane want to recognize represent of MS
MR chairman just a quick question you
mentioned about turning off phones which
is thank you for reminding me um any
restrictions on having laptops iPads on
the desk I know some of you use that for
you know taking notes so as long as
you're not using it as a
distraction then fine because I see
represent of
Murray takes notes on it so and and
we've been doing that for a while so
that's that's the way it works that's
the way it works and you know you're not
taking phone calls on it or anything
else if you do do it
silently thank
you Mr
Kane thank you good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Michael Kaine the
legislative budget assistant uh with me
I have some of my staff they're not
going to stay for the whole orientation
because they don't want to listen to me
but at the same time they have fiscal
notes and presentations they're going to
talk to you later um just quickly about
myself um Michael Kane uh I came to New
Hampshire in 1999 working for the
legislative budget assistant and I've
been here ever since so it's my 25th
year uh with the office uh next to me we
have our senior budget officer uh Mick
landrian who's going to be working with
division 2 and behind me we have uh Jack
Mullen who's going to be working with
division one Melissa Rollins is going to
be working with Jack in division one and
then Kevin Ripple uh working with
division 3 who you don't see here today
from the budget division is uh Chris
Shay who's the deputy LBA uh he has
another obligation but he does say hello
Chris also works with the ways means
meeting the capital budget uh overview
committees um during the development of
the capital budget and revenue estimates
um and then we have Pam Ellis who's
probably listening back at the office uh
issuing thousands of fiscal notes and
rules uh she keeps the office going so
Pam Alis has been with our office for
close to 17 years uh we also have um an
audit division of 22 Auditors currently
we usually run between 22 and 24 uh
split almost evenly between performance
Auditors and financial Auditors and
they're located outside of the State
House in the TD Bank building uh across
the street from the former holiday
in so I'm going to begin um the quick um
I call it a quick orientation um we
stopped calling it a budget briefing
because it is 93 pages but I can
guarantee you I will not be going
through every page this is more of a
reference document we do post it online
um so you can use this as a coaster or
placeholder uh but we do have it online
for members of the public and it does
have some good information relative to
budget terms you're going to be hearing
uh for the new members and for members
of the public um documents you should
get used to seeing as we go through the
process um and other things it's
probably the smallest document we're
going to be handing to you because when
the budget comes out uh you'll be
receiving an 800 page document of house
bill one for the
Appropriations and probably another 100
or so pages with a trailer bill so um
this is just the beginning we'd like to
break you in by handing a an unwieldy
document to you right off the start but
I I'll walk you through this uh just on
page two or page one uh the second page
right behind the cover is just a staff
directory uh we're located in State
House Room 101 and 102 and we also have
some basement offices uh but you can see
a staff listing as well as our numbers
and the new email addresses you may have
all been notified that the journal code
is moving from an
l.n. us to a simpler gc. nh.gov I
believe this will be going live um next
week um you can still email us at either
address and it'll come through to us uh
but we did just want to make sure since
it is a document online we have the the
new
structure on page two are just some
common terms to find for those of you
who have not been uh part of fin Finance
um there are some um some good
definitions here I will not going
through all of them one of the most
important you're going to hear is
accounting unit accounting unit is a
component of the budget um for your
agencies on where a certain program is
funded um so there are hundreds several
hundred accounting units that you'll be
seeing in your divisions uh so as you
hear that term uh there's usually a
number code that goes along with it that
our analyst will walk you through
today appropriation being the
authorization granted by the legislative
body um the appropriation is an
authorization to expend so it's
basically the you're giving the agency
the okay to spend up to a certain amount
um Appropriations are also sometimes
granted through the fiscal committee
which is a 10- member uh Joint Committee
of the general court who approves
additional acceptance of additional
federal funds and other funds in in rare
cases in minimal cases for General funds
for judicial counsel uh Department of
Justice and Department of Corrections
and a couple of other agencies
um and just a footnote for the new
members what's a footnote you'll see
text in house bill one that will have
restrictions on how the Appropriations
can be spent or how they can be
transferred for instance you may have a
footnote in the budget which our analyst
will go over with you that maybe allows
the agency to not lapse the funds not or
carry forward any unexpended funds until
the next year uh May Place limits on
whether or not the funds can be
transferred in or out into those
particular class lines which are the
smaller unit of expenditures and uh laps
is a number you're going to be hearing
uh laps is a number is basically
unexpended Appropriations uh for the
past four years it hasn't received a lot
of attention because the revenues from a
budget perspective were over budget uh
if we go back uh a few years
ago this was an item that the lapse
number is the unexpended Appropriations
that the legislature assumes will not be
spent to allow a balanced budget so it's
up to the executive branch to balance
the budget which assumes the amount of
Revenue coming in the amount of
authorized expense and then the the
labster unexpended Appropriations and
that can occur from things like
vacancies staff vacancies be uh being
one of the big uh portions of laps
representative Wilder had asked how much
uh salaries and benefits make up of a
total budget usually between 25 and 26 %
of your general fund spending is uh U
employment um so laps figures uh from
estimates that are different from what
was projected almost two years ago so
even though the the finance committees
do the best they can to appropriate what
they think will be needed for the next
two years things change contracts take a
little longer um the economy changes
utilization changes for programs and so
that lapse does occur and then a surplus
deficit statement you'll see in an
example later on in here um which is
really a document that we prepare the
governor prepares and then we prepare
for the House and Senate to ensure that
the state passes a balanced budget plan
uh for the next two
years RSA uh 9 is the uh portion of of
the state statute relative to
Appropriations uh and expenditures uh
just a c a couple of um sections out
take you to is on page four uh RSA 92 is
transmission to the legislature this is
a requirement that the governor present
uh his or her budget by February 15th of
the um odd number year so this year
February 15th falls on a Saturday uh
typically the governor will present uh
to the Full House and Senate um in joint
session my guess is I don't know the
exact dates you'd have to reach out to
the governor my guess so would happen
around the 12th or 13th most likely it's
not going to happen on Saturday but it's
never happened before but you never say
never so um but that is the deadline in
statute that the governor must submit uh
the operating budget to the legislature
uh in addition that was put in a few
years ago RSA
992a uh on top of the operating budget
there's a bill that goes along with it
that is called referred to as the
trailer Bill and those are all the
statutory changes necessary to implement
it didn't effectuate the changes in the
budget uh there were a couple years ago
we put in uh we being the the state of
Hampshire put into the irsa uh a
requirement that the trailer Bill also
be submitted by the governor by February
15th um for some of you who have been on
finance for a while there were years
when you wait a good three weeks prior
to seeing the language that is in the
trailer Bill and it does delay the
ability of the finance committee to
really look at that budget policy and
make
decisions uh within a short period of
time uh on page five there's one
sentence I'll point out up top that was
just added um although there was always
a requirement that or not always but
with the last couple years a requirement
to submit the trailer Bill uh it was in
printed format um in an electronic
computer format but it wasn't publicly
posted online so members of the public
and members of of the legislature would
hear what was potentially in the trailer
bill but until it was introduced in
House Bill 2 um they couldn't see it so
the new sentence was added that um the
document shall be um available printed
format one electronic but and shall be
publicly posted on the department of
administrative services website on the
data transmittal um so there's a
requirement that by February 15th all
the text of houseville 2 needs to be put
on the department of administrator's
website uh so that should help uh the
the members of Finance understand and
members of the public understand what
the governor is proposing in their
budget Mr chair yes thank you I just
want to ask a clarifying question so
what is the delay then are you all are
you in your office and uh are you
drafting hb2 at that point are you just
getting the information from the
governor's Budget on the 15th and then
you have to draft the actual language
like what is that delay yes thank you so
we will uh our office will receive and
the office of legislative Services who
drafts legislation we receive a copy
from the governor's legal council uh of
the text of House Bill Tu the office of
legislative services will then spend
usually takes about a week to two weeks
depending on how large it is to actually
draft and introduce a or draft a
legislation for introduction in house
bill to so because the trail Bill
usually has several changes to statute
various stat you uh various effective
dates um components that do relate it
does take the drafters the legisl
drafters usually about a week to two
weeks um usually closer to the two weeks
to get the final text the legislative
text available and that has been the
delay in the past because the public
would not see any of that text until
that bill was introduced hopefully this
the sentence that was added last year
will at least have that text in a non
let necessary not a legislative format
yet there will be some tweaks to it but
the subjects will be there it'll be in
the best uh attempt by the governor's
office to put it into um statutory
language uh and then we'll have the
final but that will at least get each
division will start to work on their
portions they'll have an idea of um what
they need to change what they agree to
what they need to learn about so great
thank you so
much uh thank you and uh as I understand
the tradition the the goal is for hb1
and
hb2 to have uh the the chair and the
division chairs as sponsors and
co-sponsors of hb1 and hb2 and then it
actually does become the finance
committee's bill
correct that's correct and that it's
important to note that the the governor
will recommend their budget but it does
not become a bill until the legislature
makes that introduction of both Health
Bill and one two um we go to the house
deadlines this year
um on page 20 um crossover the last day
for I'm going to start with the
crossover day last day to act on all
house bills is April 10th um that means
that all bills including the budget need
to be reported out by this committee on
April 3rd um our analysts will go uh
work with you over the next uh several
weeks uh once we do get the budget to uh
provide some deadlines to you to help
you to meet that goal typically one or
two days prior to the reporting out of
the committee uh the divisions will
present their uh budget recommendations
to the full committee for a vote which
will then be after the vote will be
compiled into one document so your final
vote will be around April 3rd um as
representative wer said the workload of
house Finance is significant uh not only
for the budget but between 50 and 100
bills depending on how they go through
the policy Committees of bills with
potential fiscal impacts on all the
agencies that you're going to look at uh
you'll get them later because the policy
committees are currently going to start
to work on those bills now you'll have a
short time period and on top of that we
like to throw the budget into it as well
so it's going to be um quite the busy
time almost like a holiday season for uh
for legislation it's just overwhelming
at times but we're here to help you
through that to make sure you meet all
those
deadlines page 22 is the um it's an
operating budget process agency phase
has started sorry yes no I I just wanted
to say before we leave this uh house
deadlines there's there's sort of an
unofficial thing that I I think Finance
members may want to keep an eye on and
that is that um right now the the
speaker is planning to do a winter break
uh the winter break is 24 through 28
February and uh in division 3 we're
hoping to have gotten our work done to
the point to where we can actually take
that week and and do something with it
but but so for the new people in
particular you just want to keep a be
aware and stay in touch with your
division chair on what you're going to
do that week you may have a chance to go
get warm somewhere or uh this continue
to toil away in a committee room
somewhere traditionally this committee
doesn't take the break because we so we
just need the time the other the other
things are we might end up working
weekends or till 10:00 at night so um if
the LBA is pretty good at scheduling
everything for us and and trying to keep
us to five days a week and and you know
full days but uh normally we we stay
here during that during that vacation
time because we don't get interrupted as
much by other committees especially the
fact that we've got some of our
committee members that are doing double
duty so that'll be one of the few weeks
that we they won't be called away so do
your best not to schedule something for
them thank
you in our um the analysts working with
your division whatever deadlines you
want or whatever schedules you have
we'll make sure that the agencies are in
and the topics are addressed in that
manner um I'm lucky to have such a
wonderful staff who does work very well
with the divisions to make sure you'll
meet your deadlines so there's no
question about that uh on page 22 is
just kind of the operating budget
process actually actually started back
in March where the agency phase the
budget agencies start presenting their
26 and 27 budget into the budget system
uh which they have until October they
then present a governor uh they receive
um instructions from the governor on
what what they should present what are
the targets what are the what are the
goal of the governor as far as where
they see revenues at the time agencies
and their agency budget request it
varied by agency but overall about a 4%
reduction uh in what they received in FY
25 uh Governor's phase began uh upon the
beginning of the governor's um right
before Veterans Day the the governor's
budget hearings and then we'll continue
through February 15th this is a a a
portion of the budget phase those first
that we're not involved in we have no
access to the budget system or
information or what's going on we only
hear basically from our agencies no
detail but what's happening and then
from February to April this year the
house will have the budget which will go
very quick it's usually even though it
looks like two months it's probably
closer to 6 weeks when you look at your
deadlines to report to have public uh uh
public hearings to have a presentation
to the Full House it's about 6 weeks so
it's going to be a tight time frame uh
but we'll get you through that when the
house passes their budget will'll go
over to the Senate who has until the
beginning of June to pass their portion
which will then come back to the house
for either U concurrence request for
commune conference or non-c concurrence
and then after that will'll go to the
governor's office um as far as the
governor's phase is involved it's going
on right now
um we're hearing just from the press and
and just looking in the governor had
went back to agencies for further
reduction
uh so you may have heard during the
governor's budget hearings the impact of
a 4% reduction or 2% reduction or an
agency uh we don't know the exact number
but we have heard agencies are putting
together additional reductions for the
governor uh so we know they're hard at
work uh the executive branch right now
so that Governor AOK can present a
balanced budget by uh February 15th uh
revenues is one of the big and kind of
going off script here but revenues is
one of the big questions uh right now we
were almost we being the state almost
$50 million under Revenue through
December um usually if you are under
Revenue um in December you'll most
likely end the year under plan so we're
taking a look at 25 right now um with
the revenues and how they're going to
perform March and April being the two
largest months unfortunately you'll be
so deep into your budget process uh you
won't have the final numbers but you
have a good indication through Midway
and March and where you think those
revenues Ways and Means Committee will
be providing this committee with uh um
revenues uh estimated revenues and that
timing is depending on discussions
amongst leadership agencies are
typically hesitant to uh provide any
solid estimates until they work with the
governor who they do um who who is their
um their employer in the executive
branch so we know they're working close
I would be you should talk to the chair
of ways and means but typically around
the beginning of March you'll have an
idea where your revenues are it's hard
to predict where they'll go but most
likely they will be low um and that's
just a just a ballpark estimate but once
the governor comes out with her
estimates on on the middle of February
you'll have a good sense of uh what is
the what you have in front of you um
it's going to be different than the last
few years those the members who have
been on the committee the last few years
um um it's
it was still hard it's always very hard
there's always needs out there that the
state needs to take care of there's
always changes in policy the state needs
to aurass uh from a revenue perspective
uh the revenues were performing very
well over the last few years uh but
that's ended and it's going to going to
end and uh that's why you have the
agencies working so hard with Governor
right now um and very very hard to
predict for 26 and 27 wayy means house
ways means sen ways means it's a very
hard task in front of them to determine
where the revenues will be for the next
2 years um one of the major reasons is
business taxes being your largest
revenue for the general and education
trust fund are so volatile and so hard
to predict but you do have a great
Commissioner of Department of Revenue
Administration who work closely with
both ways and means committee to give
them the best estimates where they are
and usually at the end of the process
the legislature does a pretty good job
of um coming to an agreement of where
they think the next two years will end
up just to uh just samples of what uh a
budget looks like um if we go into um
the pages are uh basically for the
online version but it's about page 25
it's just more numbers uh in code this
is a very un non-reader friendly
document but this is a copy of house
bill one these are the Appropriations
that are put into the accounting system
so as the agencies are ready to pay make
payments uh payroll bills these are the
accounts that they come off of in the
event that these accounts are not the
proper place to have the money the
agencies uh for any transfers over
$100,000 has to ask the fiscal committee
for approval to make that transfer uh we
make sure that it's allowable and then
it goes forward but $800 pages of
numbers like this is really hard to find
what you're looking for this is actually
summarized which is kind of funny
because there's um object codes beneath
the classes uh probably 20 for each one
so that's a very hard document to look
at so the the classes the Personnel
Services in class 10 benefits in class
60 are really uh consolidated into one
so if you have a constituent or you're
interested in one certain program it's
very hard to find in here reach out to
us we'll locate that for you and
sometimes we have to ask agencies and
dig deeper you'll have $200 million
class lines in health and human services
that fund 40 or 50 contracts so but
you're not going to be able to see that
from house one nor will your
constituents or the public so we can
help dig down and provide that
information to you ask the agency to
provide that detail to you um and also
just to um remind everyone we share
everything online we put everything
that's handed out in the division online
so that the members of the public uh and
members of the legislature when you're
doing other things can go back and
reference those documents um to kind of
pay attention to um what each division
is
doing yes thank you Mr chair I wonder if
if you could just um
identify uh which of the ite items on
this this sample page tie back to the
definitions on page two you know uh
accounting unit category class line
what's an example of each of those thank
thank you thank you so accounting unit
if we look at the example of uh House
Bill one um the what we refer to as
accounting unit or the on the left hand
side of the page the 01 General
government so
01044 0410
1170 we consider that to be the full
chain of the accounting unit as you get
into looking at the budget a little more
you'll start referring to the accounting
unit by the last four for instance
1170 um depending on your division but
that is the accounting unit um the next
the three digits but below that with the
the classifications of the
Appropriations those are called
classes so class 11 for the Senate
Personnel Services unclass classified
class 060 is benefits um in class um
just another example class 080 is out of
state travel uh so there are unique
these are all unique classes for each
agency so that there's consistency
across the agency and the accounting
units that the spending is happening in
the same account so when representative
wer asked a question of kind of how much
there's uh salary and benefits as a
percentage of the budget we'll use a
budget by class because we know it's
consistent across all departments and
we'll just add the percentages there so
and then um the footnote that I
referenced previously if you look it's
called organization notes you can see
there's an aster um and in this in uh in
this case it's president of the Senate
designating permanent employees and the
benefits that they're eligible to
receive so you'll see the aster you'll
see the the note the word note uh when
those footnotes do come up um and so
that's from that page I think those are
the the main pieces of information
you'll
need sure um
a document that we will prepare is on on
page 32 it's called a compare document
um the governor will present a budget
and the house is going to make changes
to that budget both in house bill one
and House Bill two uh we prepare
document called a a compare report so
you can see the differences between what
the house is proposing and what the
governor is proposing we run this on a
regular basis back in our office to make
sure that we're keeping track of all the
ch es so we can present uh estimates to
the chairs to let them know that excuse
me that their budget is balanced and and
to track all those changes um so for
instance if you were to look at that
compare report you can see um I believe
it's under Consultants um the house
added $10,000 to the Senate uh and they
reduced under Personnel Services $10,000
so you can see the class line they make
the changes and then the total this was
a net zero but uh you'll have this for
every account accounting unit uh that
will
print page uh 34 if you're wondering why
there's a one andit two and they're not
Al together well the Constitution does
not allow changes to statute to be
included in the budget bill so the
legislature and their wisdom has
determined that we can just have a bill
follow it along call it the trailer Bill
and House Bill 2 and that will have all
the necessary statutory changes and then
comply with um the constitution on that
side on page 35 as beginning of House
Bill 2 uh just the um now these are all
the a couple examples what does House
Bill 2 do that house bill one can't do
um well it can't rename divisions of the
Department of Information Technology
without making changes to statute so
that has to be into house bill too uh
authorizing agencies separate from
what's authorized in RSA to fill
unfunded positions that needs to be made
in House Bill too so our analyst will
work with you any changes you're
proposing in the budget that we believe
needs to have a corresponding house
build two change we will assist you in
drafting those um and it's become pretty
large over the last uh couple of
years few hundred sections which is a
lot
um I do remember the day the good good
old days when there could be 10 or 12
sections but it has grown over time um
another one of the reasons it's grown is
because there are a lot of uh changes um
changes in the budget that do require
changes in statute if you're going to
require uh Dees to no longer do
something you have to make sure there's
not a statutory requirement to do so uh
but the other reason is bills uh as
representative Wilder mentioned this
several bills are going to come to house
finance there's several bills are going
to go to Senate Finance um there are
1,00 bills that will probably be
introduced at the beginning of this
section that uh the session that are
going to go through the policy
committees and live or die through there
uh over the last couple of years we've
noticed uh both the house and the Senate
um if there's a major policy that they
want uh sometimes they include it in
House Bill too so it may be something
the house has passed or they know that
the Senate may not want to include in
their proposals for legislation that
they'll put into house bill too Senate
does the same thing watch what happens
with their bills over in the Senate
maybe put them to the house bill too uh
why because then it's a simpler to kill
a bill on its own it's harder to kill a
bill when it's part of a larger process
and so that's what's happened over the
last uh couple of years that may or may
not continue um but it's something that
because that does happen our analysts
from the be uh moment it's introduced we
are tracking bills that go through the
committee even if they aren't in house
bill one or two we're paying attention
because at one time they may come here
uh to finance and make a 20 to the
budget
can I just make a point on that sure so
the constitution in the in the section
just prior to the one you mentioned
requires that all money bills start in
the house so what the Senate will
frequently do when they want to spend
money on X they might have a Bill of
their own they pass it and then they
table it and then they modify House Bill
two because it's a house bill to to make
that change right so so they can't
effective they get around that
constitutional Thing by changing House
Bill a house bill to do it rather than
having Senate bill one two three do
it yes the legislative is very cre
legislature is very creative over the 25
years I've seen a lot haven't seen
everything and like but uh yes the
Senate will table a lot of bills you'll
see Senate Finance with a lot of
introduced bills with Appropriations
that they'll table in the past bills
that were tabled maybe they didn't uh
they go forward and
uh they die on the table at the end of
the two years but with the Senate they
will hold out because there will be
introduced Senate bills with
Appropriations and the Senate just does
not know if they can fit it within their
budget proposal yet so they'll hold it
off to the side eventually put it into
house bill two if they decide um on page
46 it's uh just a onepage of a surplus
statement just to give you an example of
what it will look like uh at the end of
the process a beginning balance of a
year for the general and education trust
fund estimated revenues uh from the
governor house Ways and Means or Senate
ways of means uh Revenue adjustments uh
Revenue adjustments usually changes in
House Bill 2 or other policy Bills going
through uh the legislature that do have
an impact on revenues uh what the uh
ways of Means Committee asked in the
house is to uh estimate base revenues
what are the revenues based on current
law not on what's proposed uh but on
current law so that's what you'll get
from house ways means but there will be
sections in uh policy other bills and in
House Bill 2 that may impact revenues uh
if there are bills that the house is uh
passing and in favoring or including
House Bill two those will be the revenue
adjustments uh that you'll see on uh row
five and so we'll track those throughout
the process we want to make sure that
yes Finance is proposing a balanced
budget based on the revenues and
Appropriations you have but if we are
aware of anything going on in the house
and the Senate that has an impact we
want to make sure the legislature passes
is a balanced budget so uh there's a
probably a three-page schedule two that
feeds up into this that has all the
detail of the different bills and
Appropriations and impact on revenues
just so we can keep track of all of that
to ensure a balanced budget um budget
Appropriations appropriation adjustments
lapses which I talked about um just a
couple numbers uh $76 million was the
estimated lapse in 24 um the agencies
actually came in with a $52 million lap
so they missed the lapse for the first
time in several years um paying
attention on 25 the estimated lapse is
$17.7 million of General funds that uh
the legislature and Governor initially
signed say that would not be spent
that's something that fiscal will start
receiving reports on fiscal will receive
a report uh in January from the
Department of administrative services on
their estimated laps back in December
and if you look at it it's only about
$30 million cuz it's very early in the
fiscal year there's not an $80 million
shortfall um but it is something that
fiscal is going to be paying attention
to and finance is going to be paying
attention to uh but chairman wer had put
a provision at the house bill to uh a
couple years ago to ensure that
Department administrative services start
updating the legislature on these laps
estimates uh the best held secret up uh
before um but to provide that
information to the
legislature and then um we'll have
similar Surplus statements in division 2
for your Highway fund uh education trust
fund and your fishing game fund um just
wanted to point out the caer when we
talk about beginning balances and what
are we going to start the current fiscal
year we're in is fiscal year
25 um you may have heard the annual
comprehensive financial report that's
the Statewide um um annual report that
will provide the be the audited
beginning balances for the current
fiscal year so for 25 so what money was
left over in the end of 24 that has been
delayed the release of that has been
delayed it's typically released in
December um that the extension was
granted by fiscal committee to push that
release date out to January 31st uh due
to uh a significant change in the
financial systems at liquor uh there
will be a further request to extend that
through the end of March uh which is
pretty late during a budget session it's
all related to this big transition from
liquor uh over into this new accounting
system our Auditors and liquor have to
identify every dollar uh to make sure
both systems are up to date and there's
a lot of testing that's required yes
representative so that's going to make
it a little more difficult for us
because we won't even know what lapsed
and what was the beginning amount of
money we had to start with with like
this shows here until after we've
finished with the
budget yes and the governor even
probably doesn't like it even more uh
the governor is going to be presenting a
budget and making the best most of the
other components of the annual financial
report won't move you might see a $10
million move one way or the other uh
liquor hopefully doesn't move any
further than it had from the beginning
so although not officially the audit
version there should be a good
there will be a good number that the
governor will begin with and the house
will have and as that's updated it will
swing a few million dollars just through
the normal audit activity but you'll
have I think you'll have a good base not
a final base but a good base where 20 uh
25 will be and then I'll provide these
snapshots throughout the year I
presented one to house ways means
earlier in the week of where we think 25
will end based on spending based on
Revenue Etc
so thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Kane just to make sure I understand
correctly we uh have uh still work to do
on the liquor
numbers while not an acfr will we have
the confidence that the numbers for
every other division will be as accurate
they as they would have been in a final
acfr so is the only uncertainty in the
liquor side or are we going to have
uncertainties in other places we will
have certainty I I work with Dana call
who's the com controller to get updates
on numbers who provides estimates of if
there's swings one way or the other uh
so it won't be audited but it'll be
pretty certain and you'll have some
movement um with like I wouldn't see
significant movement so anything the
governor puts out in her Surplus
statement and anything that we provide
in the house will be pretty certain just
not audited until it's finalized
sure okay um and through no fault just
to point out I know fisc will be talking
about it why is there a delay there
hasn't been delay in a while you know we
do have to look back uh 15 years or so
before there was delay uh in audit but
this is a significant change to Liquor's
Financial system one that've been
working on for over a decade that was
implemented at the end of April um of
the other fiscal year you have to make
sure both systems line up and every
dollar is accounted for liquor there was
a delay getting that information because
they want to make sure that our Auditors
have the right information our Auditors
need time to understand that system to
give when the final audit is issued
those are the numbers so although it is
delay it is a necessary delay in my
opinion just to make sure we're giving
uh the state and and the public the
proper numbers um so there are a couple
uh just two uh charts we included in
this and I won't I won't take too much
longer but I'll answer some questions
but the operating budget for 2425 total
funds about $ 15 uh billion you can see
the top green line up there is federal
funds almost $4.7 million is federal so
that's on page it's in the staple 49 but
uh it's up top because we have it
paginated based on the uh web thing so I
do apologize so page 49 uh right after
the example of the fishing game Surplus
statement you'll see this uh up line
chart uh federal funds have about 4.7
4.8 general fund the next largest source
at about 3.7 uh other funds of about 2.9
almost 3 billion ion dollar of other
funds those are transfers relative to
doit that is agency income restricted
for Agency use so that's a significant
portion of the budget that you'll all be
looking at and education fund at about
2.5 Highway fund about 563 million
Turnpike 292 liquor 178 if you look at
liquor in the total you'd see it's a
smaller number as far as your as your
budget figures are concerned uh fishing
game about 33 and sweep sakes a little
under 32 so we know um that's where as
far as the source of funds where that
comes
from I I I I do have a question um since
I'm I'm not in division two could could
you just remind me um what the key
source is for funds going into the
education fund and what the what the uh
the current standards are for keeping
those money segregated from the general
fund yep the largest not a long
explanation just kind of a highlight uh
Statewide property tax is um the largest
that's about 300 over two years this is
a two-year chart that's about $720
million the Statewide property tax um
and then you have business Enterprise
taxes another few hundred million so
those are the two main components all
lottery Revenue any Lottery profit needs
to by Statute and Constitution be used
for Education that goes into the
education trust fund so we can provide
it we'll provide a breakdown and
divisions of those components how that
money is spent in the education trust
fund is driven by Statute what is
allowable and and that determination is
also made during the budget process
there have been items that have been
moved to the education trust fund over
the last couple years uh that the
statute was changed to allow that so
that will be up to all of you and the
legislature to make that determination
in the event that something you want to
spend education trust fund on another
use
Mickey uh in division 2 will make sure
that statute is consistent with the
actions that you're
taking
okay and if we go um just to the pie
chart um the categories on page 50 this
is one of the pie charts representative
wer will do the couple other pie charts
you like we've been doing for the last
20 years but on kind of where the
sources of funds are where the
categories are uh Revenue
uh but this one is by category so if you
look at the $15 billion of the budget
for 2425 you can see a large piece of
high down the bottom in representative
Edwards that's division three uh that's
Health and Human Services so uh Health
and Human Services makes up over 50% of
the budget pushing close to 60%
depending on what the governor presents
so that's one of the larger followed by
education education trust fund uh and
general funds that's $3.4 billion
and then you have other uh category one
of General government which Jack Mullen
will be working with division one is
about a billion uh category two and
three not including safety and fishing
game which Melissa will be working with
uh is about another 1.7 and8 that's
almost $2.5 billion and then category
four of Transportation including federal
funds including Turnpike is about one
and a half uh so um HHS and education
your two biggest um sources uh
portions of the budget right now and
have been uh over the last uh decades uh
page 51 is fiscal committee statute the
fiscal committee is responsible as I
mentioned to allow agencies after the
budget has passed to transfer to
transfer funds in between Class lines to
accept additional funds that maybe the
budget writers were not aware of uh
competitive Grant or other additional
funds over estimates needs to receive
legislative approval again from The
Authority designated to fiscal committee
to approve that and then the last uh
several Pages you can see all the money
over the last few years that have come
in uh we keep track of that come in
through fiscal in a typical uh banian
pre pandemic we were probably about $150
to $200 million of uh Federal and other
funds came in through fiscal um with
arpa uh with car's act there were close
to a billion dollars in um funds that
came in outside of the budget process
process uh most recently you're close to
uh about $500 million a year in arpa
funds uh that were coming in outside of
the budget process the reason those came
in outside of the budget process your
arpa and caros funds is because it's not
an ongoing program it's not operating
expenses these are one-time uh expenses
that the legislature and Governor
decided it's best to keep them separate
just for when you're doing budget
comparisons you're not watching it go up
by 3 billion dollars and then back down
and wondering what happened this is a
one a point in time um one-time use of
these funds and that's what you'll three
uh see through those uh fiscal committee
actions just to uh wrap up I've I've
included a couple of pages examples of
what you'll see in the cafer uh there'll
be a surplus statement that will come
out an official audited Surplus
statement what we'll provide to the
committee is not an audited Surplus
statement it's a surplus statement for a
budget plan uh the CF rle also when
that's finalized provide you a great
10-year history of fund balances for the
general education fishing game and all
the other funds it'll provide you with a
history of employees uh representative
wer mentioned paychecks over the last 12
months that are issued uh the caer will
also provide you with a 10-year look
back a number of employees uh by
agencies that each division kind of see
the trend or or or what's growing um and
then I just left put a couple of
examples of what are we going to provide
the divisions we provide uh we'll help
draft uh amendments that are necessary
to H Bill one or two will keep track of
the financial uh changes that each
division is making um work with your
analysts in your Division and come up
with a format that you think will be
most helpful for your division um and we
can prepare anything you need and then
uh finally we'll do a detail Change
Report to kind of provide a similar to
the compare Report with a little more
description of what's going to happen or
what was behind some of the decisions um
you know just so the public may see a
reduction of $100,000 but it doesn't
tell you anything we like to do a detail
change document which is an example um I
think there's on page 91 near the end of
kind of what we like to provide uh out
to the public um and that's kind of the
process
um it's going to be a tough budget and I
I think everything you've heard over the
last week everything you've it's going
to be a tough budget but
um it's there are no easy ones even the
ones with significant there were no easy
budgets I think ask representative wer
and ask representative Wallner if
they've ever seen an easy budget the
answer will probably be no for for many
different reasons um but you do have a
great staff Financial staff out in the
agencies that will assist you and
provide you any information you need uh
our staff is there to help coordinate
that and get that for you and put it in
a format uh that is uh that will be most
helpful to you so we're here for you and
we're looking forward to working with
you over the next several weeks thank
you and uh the work we've had from from
the LBA is is the only thing that
enabled us to do our job these These are
people are very good at this we'll sit
there all day doing stuff and then we'll
go home home at 4 or 5:00 at night and
the next morning we're ready to start
again they've been up all night making
sure everything that we we did during
that negotiation got put in a format
that we can look at the next day and say
okay otherwise one of us would be up all
night doing that stuff so got to hand it
to them they don't take vacations during
the budget time they maybe have a little
time off later on in the year one of the
other things that that came to mind when
I did the paycheck count there were
there are things that come before fiscal
that will be a um a temporary thing and
so one of the questions we might ask
where we see a change in in uh paychecks
that lasts for a period uh was there a a
grant that gave you this because those
people would still be in that department
and they would still be getting
paychecks that wouldn't deduct the ones
that were ontemporary or there as a
result so if we if we do see some
numbers like that follow on question is
are there any um grants that have
expired because along when when we do
approve those those um grants at fiscal
and five of us here are on fiscal and
couple others that are alternates so
when we do see a grant go come in and
it'll say We'll hire these people and
it'll say in the fine print that when
they when the grant expires the jobs go
away so we have to ensure that that in
fact happens and see so one of the
things as we look at paychecks is how
many grants have expired during this 12
months and see if in fact the jobs went
away so just something that came to me
as we were having this discussion that I
hadn't mentioned earlier so any further
questions from the
LBA representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair I I just want to uh share a
little bit more of my experience with
working with LBA with specifically with
Mr Ripple the last two terms and um and
this may be I'm saying this because I
think it's beneficial as an orientation
issue um uh I I have found uh Mr Ripple
uh extremely capable of talking um to
the uh Democrats and to the Republicans
about what uh kind of analysis we want
to have done and what sort of
information we need so that we can have
a debate and committee and uh and he's
exceptionally trustworthy and I'm sure
that's true of all the lbas to maintain
discretion so that the members are the
ones controlling the information and
controlling the debate and so I think
that discretion is extremely honorable
and useful for the effective functioning
of the Committees I appreciate that um
also uh when we take up bills um and we
have have um some amendments that we
would like to debate and consider um Mr
Ripple uh is exceptionally good at
working with OSS to get the Amendments
turned around and that's a that's a
vital function for us to get those
things done quickly and correctly so I I
I I just want to point that out as a as
an LBA service that I don't think you
you headlined today but but it's vital
uh and I also think that um the fact
that our LBA works with the house side
of finance and the Senate side of
finance and while he uh the that
discretion that I talked about is
maintained I think the situational
awareness of what the Senate is thinking
and talking about is uh is extremely
useful to us too so so there there are
many more layers to how great I think
the LBA is and and we simply uh you know
from my perspective we we could not do
this job without the LBA it's it's vital
they're vital team members and um and I
just appreciate the four years of having
worked with them so uh thank you I hope
that was useful thank
you thank you Mr chairman so um there
are some cases in the budget of double
counting particularly for the best
example is probably doit right because
one agency uh puts in their budget we're
spending so much on uh Information
Technology then doit gets that money as
income and then spends it on salaries
and so on so how do we how do we sort of
find these kind of numbers and when we
see things like your big pie chart do
that include double counting or is it
already taken out
somehow uh thank you representative so
uh the pie charts are gross so it's
everything double counting and
everything uh but as far as um how much
double counting there is between
transfers because both the sending
agency and the spending agency need to
have that authority to actually make
those expenditures on page 26 of of this
document it um which was this was just
added probably about um three budgets
ago if you look at the totals you can
see that uh the total funds uh they have
the various sources the total funds
about 7.4 billion in 24 7.6 billion in
in
25 less funds for Budget Revenue
transfers other funds about $289 million
that's the double counting in 24 and
about 289 290 in 25 and so in total the
budget is closer to a 14 if you take out
the double counting is closer to a 145
every accounting unit that has a
transfer uh to another agency or
receives a transfer from another agency
you will see that line less funds from
budgeted Revenue transfers so as you go
through the budget you'll see the total
the gross total plus the net total after
you get rid of the transfers so you'll
be able to monitor that for every
accounting unit excellent thank
you okay here we are drinking from a
fire hose any further questions
representative Mo thank you very much Mr
chairman thank you Mr Kane for all you
do I'm glad to see on page 90 you have
an example of an appropriation bill and
there's curious language that repeatedly
comes up that I thought maybe you could
just give some insight to and let us
know how often it happens and that
appears on lines seven and 8 on page 90
the governor authorized to draw a
warrant a very little discussion ever
occurs with regards to that line but we
see it over and over could you expand on
that and let us know how often that
occurs thank you sure thank you
representative Mooney um any general
fund appropriation
uh through a a section requires that
language it has to the government needs
the
um the the authorization from the
legislature to draw a warrant it's
obviously up to the governor legislature
can't force the governor do anything so
the languages May draw a warrant uh what
a warrant is is an authorization from
the governor that he provides in a
letter to the Department of
administrative services that sets up
that accounting unit uh you'll only see
that if you do see that language in that
sentence that's a general fund uh that's
going to be hit on the general fund uh
Department if it was a highway fund
appropriation it says shall be a charge
against the highway fund fishing game
Etc uh so that warrant language is
required and as we're looking at any
bill that's being introduced the 1100
bills uh we're looking for draw warrant
because that means that's a general fund
and that's the necessary language for
the governor to actually provide that
letter to Department of administrative
services to draw that money from the
general fund and they do have that
warrant Authority in the beginning of
house bill one for the major House Bill
one but any appropriation in House Bill
2 from the general fund needs that
language and that's something we'll
check to make sure it's there
okay further questions from the
committee okay so we're back at 1:00
you'll go to your divisions uh division
chairs might want to work on the seating
charts in the interim and have have your
seating charts ready for your division
iions um your your division LBA people
will will be there to brief you on
what's going to what's going to be done
in each division that will be in the
afternoon starting at
1:00 um enjoy representative Edwards
thank you thank you representative wer
um there's there we're calling a little
bit of an audible here on what we're
doing with the division 3 um uh because
it conflicts with HHS ea uh doing their
DHHS
orientation uh I I've been asking and
have permission from the chair there to
have our uh division three go
participate in that DHHS orientation so
because I'm it's at one and I think my
folks know that um okay and um and so
what I'll just be doing is I'll by
myself uh come and start division 3's
orientation and and and recess it or
close it whatever the right thing to do
is just to keep us clear on the calendar
time later on after the other one yeah
and I I think this was such a great
orientation uh and so much information
that we're probably full for the day
anyways does every member know what
division they
run very
good all right let's break for lunch and
uh division three has a has a different
plan division one and two have their own
rooms division one over here division
two across the hall in that smaller room
and uh welcome to finance committee
thank you all for your attendance um I'm
impressed with your backgrounds and and
I know that we'll get some good work
done here I thank you all for your
attendance have a good lunch thank you
are you going to come over with us this
afternoon or yeah
okay move so yeah yeah so have you have
you got a seating plan done e